fighting
out of rhode island
the challenger
coming in at five two to five four ish
small five and a half watch out julie
with a much much more accomplished older
brother
with a challenger
christian
meatball
and now
the returning champion
what are the biggest asians you'll ever
see
205 6'3
i'm guessing
coming fighting out of south korea
chin
yee
[Music]
so you're on tinder yeah i i'm back on
tinder um after you know a sabbatical
from it um and i had you know i was
going out with this girl uh she was a
lawyer so i was like already out of my
out of my level of what i think i should
be dating uh but we went to a rave
together oh by the way this is cats
after dark and this is kyle and we're
hearing about his dating i'm back um
multiple
christian george george you know the
same crew that's here every week
consistently coming in
to your home uh oh and chewie chewie's
here he's another uh constant of the
podcast so lawyer okay okay yeah where
this is going yeah so i was like okay
you know smart girl will have fun she's
like let's go to a rave i was like i've
never been let's [ __ ] party uh it was
terrible
never again um i didn't drink because i
was being a square i was like i'll just
dance sober uh she got hammered
so i had to kind of babysit
a little bit and that was not great so
i'm back off the dating apps unless you
are single and watch this episode then
i'm back on but there's more to it right
so you
you didn't want to drink and she kept
asking you to drink constantly right yes
i told her several times i'm driving for
one um and then i i just had not drank
in a while um but yeah she kept trying
to get me to to drink and party uh i
didn't so she'll be probably never had
you said let's party that's true that's
true i guess there's different you know
to be fair to her i mean you go on a
date you're going to a rave maybe there
should be some i i'm not faulting her
for thinking there should be alcohol
involved yeah no it's not the fault at
all but she shouldn't be getting so yeah
yeah the fact that she was drunk i
couldn't even enjoy a conversation with
her i mean yeah it sounds like you're
looking for love kyle but if you weren't
looking for love it sounds like it would
have been the best first date of all
time hell yeah
did she take drugs um i don't not that i
saw
but um sound like a lawyer already
it wasn't in my car
um
yeah i mean it happens guys
uh so
raves i've never i've never really been
i have taken a decent amount of mdma but
uh
uh anybody rave
i feel like you'll probably bend a few
i've been to that the first one i wanted
this place called narnia
okay mr tumnus first time
in the way in the closet
the big line oh no no i don't i've never
seen narnia the movie either it's uh
it's pretty it's pretty awesome it's
actually an allegory for christ
oh really never knew yeah c.s lewis is a
big christian i think the lions jesus
wow we watched it in senior year
religion class i went to a catholic
school see i want to try and the turkish
delight is god
is that true
[Laughter]
i've only seen the first movie but it
was it was really good but anyways you
were you were getting [ __ ] up in
narnia sounds awesome no my soul me and
my buddy it was all our friends right
but me and my buddy thought it was so
smart to take peppermint schnapps and
chase it with milk because you'll get
rid of alcohol it tastes like that right
we gotta ruin milk we got so [ __ ] up
not just messed up but sick from the
alcohol and the milk the constant
alcohol and milk it was the worst thing
yeah it's a heavy stomach yeah it's very
horrible
what alcohol were you drinking
peppermint schnapps that's the worst
kind you could do it's a peppermint
taste
is it milk already dicey for asians yeah
yeah that's like everything everything
was dicey for us
who drinks peppermint
hard liquor and then milk you know oh i
know people don't love them
don't make fun of the peppermint liquor
it was your wrong decision to drink the
milk with yeah if you thought it was you
should have done water people do rumple
mines and water it's like brushing your
teeth i did that for like four months
straight and didn't brush my teeth
that's good yeah or maybe uh peppermint
schnapps and magic mind what did that
one existed back then two minutes into
the podcast
often generally is what i what i told
them and i always forget
george just saves my ass before the end
of the episode every time by reminding
me but uh yeah magic mind we love it
it's magic stress less maybe it's gonna
heal my mind whoa i like that thank you
i'm available sorry a little bit
it sounded like five thousand
twenty-five just watched the parks and
rec episode episode where little
sebastian dies
five thousand candles in the wind mm-hmm
wow best way to ruin it for me well dude
didn't know he died because it's magic
it's mindful and we're here with nick
and chen
that i don't know if it's going to
replace this little brow song but it is
beautiful
uh but this is magic mom the magic mind
the ones i haven't taken mine that's why
i [ __ ] that up but uh magic mind the
once daily anti-procrastination drink do
more stress less take this once daily
shot it's got 12 natural ingredients
matcha based drink echinacea ashwagandha
all these good nootropic type things
you're hearing that are popping off and
you take it once and you're gonna have
less stress and not be afraid and have
that anxiety to attack your tasks uh
george has been taking it going to open
mics yeah finally getting off his ass
finally not bombing you know standing
hoes should really have been helping a
lot yeah i love it
go to magicmind.com
use promo code dark for 20 off and uh
yeah it's put in your life routine i
think even this this was water in a shot
i think waking up and taking a shot of
water every day will help your life this
has other benefits as well there's no
downside yeah my favorite benefit is the
cat's promo code uh cat's a d what is
the promo code i'm sorry dark dark yeah
dark promo code dart
good job george magic magicmind.com
promo code dark
dope
uh
so you guys sent a very interesting
picture from the other well we talked
about you guys are training you're in
bellator camp
yeah kind of kind of yeah
honestly for some of their undercards
you guys could already fight
i went to i went to a bellator card in
iowa one time and like the early prelim
fights are literally like it's like
locals sign up
if you can if you can sell 30 tickets
you're on the card it's a bringer show
yeah
that's literally what local mma is like
oh also on july 29th there is uh lfa
which is a pretty decent mma league it's
basically like a minor league
when champion people become champions in
lfa they usually go on to uh the ufc but
july 29th commerce casino which is only
like 10 minutes from downtown l.a
there's fights and i'm definitely going
i think we should all go that'd be
[ __ ] fun 29th yeah there's
a friday it's at a casino not that far
there's nothing like live fights it's
awesome
especially in smaller venues like that
where you can sit really close for cheap
uh it's the [ __ ] so i'll be there
whoever whoever wants to think i'm
hoping yeah i don't see anything on the
calendar oh that'll be dope well you
have to check the calendar wow we have
just more responsibility you know yeah
yeah yeah we got to reach out to lfa
because honestly this is probably like
some of the biggest promotions they have
they don't have like a big marketing
budget and stuff it's on it's usually on
ufc fight pass but
uh i i love it they put on really good
shows and it'd be cool to see a show
like that it's gonna be fun it's gonna
be fun i was at the one time i went to
lfa when i worked for the adam corolla
show
and we got like press passes and stuff
and
it was the day that muhammad ali died
and they announced it uh and it was like
all combat sports fan so it was like
really emotional it was it was cool
well not cool that's the wrong way it
was cool to see he was gonna die it was
cool to be at a place where
he was so reverent reverential towards
him uh back then but yeah so what what
is the camp called that you guys are in
so the camp is called uh ulta training
and it's
all the training is like they have a
whole bunch of like franchises i guess
like all around the world um but ours is
based out of uh legacy burbank it's like
a 20-week fight camp um
being trained by like some gnarly dudes
uh is there any are there pro fighters
or their names we'd recognize what's uh
alberto uh alberto crane crane it's a
legendary jiu jitsu guy uh
they said uh way back in the day rhonda
step like started going there like when
she first started uh dc dom or not
dominic crew the daniel cormier comes in
sometimes to like teach a little bit
just have fun it's like
it's like professional training
but kind of like
more sped through more generalized
because it's 20 weeks and then at the
end we can have a smoker fight
which i'm super down for exactly the
question yeah you're actually down to do
the smoker fight and josh thompson and
big john mccarthy called me and george
out yeah because they have their guy
like podcast dave
he's in it also in austin so he's like
starting i think maybe a few days before
us maybe he's doing this week we're
starting on monday
um so yeah they were talking about on
their podcast like oh like thick boy
versus weighing in kind of thing dude
that you you gotta represent me i want
keto george to sleep this year
i'm trying to [ __ ] here we go here we go
however if like we should play this
especially for this show like we should
play this up as much as as much as
possible i'll i'll help any way we can i
love that you guys are like living out
my dream uh when we had caleb presley on
this past weekend like three or four
years ago i was like i want to do rough
and rowdy it's like you you totally
could like name the time and stuff um
and then i kind of like
i don't know
i was more like thinking we should do it
through our own channels rather than
like me go on rough and rowdy but the
idea of like calling out another podcast
producer was like in my head and you
guys are doing it you and chin were
supposed to fight for forever i i've
also wanted to just get gloves and we
have we have uh cats cats fight club we
have one minute sparring sessions during
the episode
hey i got gloves in the car me too
oh [ __ ] it's getting real
one minute one minute fight club this is
numbies all over it should we all the
wheel
do we want to do this
right depict our opponents yeah two
people with two people i don't know if
nick's our chance but they can handle no
so i got my epidural shot so i can
handle it we can [ __ ] you up
it's still not fixed it's probably gonna
[ __ ] it up worse but i'm still down to
do it
don't uh let's put it right there it's a
there's a good shot huh
uh we'll just switch out the people's
names uh
so s will have to be
you remember this
harris
okay cause there's an s in his
and
your t
because you're on there kyle aren't you
um let's see
i don't see my name on it oh dude
is there anything enough there all right
you're right you're right christian i'm
sorry you got put our names on there
what if we didn't
what if we did colors
we don't have a pool so that would be
hard we got time no run
but yeah the thing is uh five days a
week uh five days a week
for 20 weeks yeah so that and it's
ending in december 3rd we're starting
next week july 18th oh it didn't start
what was the picture it was orientation
orientation and it was like we did like
a light workout in that and then so yeah
starts july 18th goes to december 3rd so
that's quite a big stretch of time
five days a week oh for real five days
and how long hour hour yeah yeah i mean
that's that's still like a lot you guys
are gonna be like
besties like yeah that's a lot of
like we could do uh like the first six
weeks we're buddy buddy and then we
started a covington mazvadol storyline
yeah
should should we cut this out you really
want to play it up no it's all right i
mean if any beef happens it'll be
natural yeah we got to get a
big boy studio apartment so we can live
together and like set up cameras
go to florida with each other you guys
are speaking my language it's a bucket
list item to produce a reality show but
also for our smoker fight brendan i'm
pretty sure volunteered to be in both of
our corners so it might be hard if
brennan is trying to corner both of us
if we fight each other you know i pray
you guys fight each other
he's been cruising for a bruising since
he [ __ ] got here yeah you know what
kyle
oh and this uh it where would the smoker
be uh do they know is it like do they
have like the same organization they use
every time or they put on their own how
it works they just told me that i get to
fight somebody and i was like that
sounds fun i love it yeah you guys are
like no questions they ask
it sounds like a dope deal and you guys
kind of got like uh to do it without
yeah it's a anybody can pay to do it
right yeah you guys got like yeah didn't
have to because it connects yeah yeah no
people
i can cut that out
uh rich ciao the matchmaker for bellator
it's his program and he offered to
volunteer me through it when he saw my
weight loss journey and then george
offered to go through it with me so i'm
not alone and scared how beautiful man
yeah hell yeah i love it i love it
that's that's really exciting um and fun
stick with it i mean
that'll change you five months like that
per day do you know um casey lydon from
mma fighting
uh he's married to that girl esther lynn
who's a photographer okay yeah i know
esther so that guy i guess he did the
same journey as you guys i think it's
the same same thing with rich child's
organization or thing and then he got
into his first mma fight so i wonder
it's on film i wonder if they show
exactly what venue they use but i'm
guessing it's like a gym yeah something
like that but
and you want his fight that's awesome
yeah he's a journalist that actually
stepped in the what was his name cage
uh casey lydon so
see he says youtube or something
he was thinking
you can't find it see where you should
be so with c-a-s-e-y
space
l-e-y d-o-n
just mma fight or something like that
uh
well richard's the man i really like
what bellator has been doing recently
their 135 pound division is [ __ ]
awesome oh they've got like they've got
like a grand prix going and uh rafael
stats who's their champ could be i don't
know top five ufc he's the man
i'm gonna say they do like uh so they
call the wimp to warrior before i guess
they changed it because it's a little
insulting i know
[Laughter]
from stupid little [ __ ]
to chad okay yeah they should have
changed it all right we got the wheel
set up if you guys are all right awesome
this will be the last minute of the
podcast but we can spin the wheel now
this is exciting
so it's it's n
for nick g
yeah yeah but what's what's the how did
we delineate between the two georges h
for harris gotcha um and then
okay okay
cool is it it's two for everybody
and then a couple blanks all right
spin it dj spin that [ __ ]
give it a real wheel
do it vanna had me for a second kyle
there we go i can't see
all right so we got you did
first all right oh wait do i gotta spin
again is that chin or christian chin i
put him for he just changed her oh yeah
you put one
[ __ ]
let's find chin's opponent
i thought i was gonna fight kyle
i'm gonna find myself chin fights
himself every single day
nick it's gonna be tough it's gonna be
tough okay meatball i've me and meatball
yeah but you got that reach no i'm
saying it's gonna be tough for me to do
it
he's like oh i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
christian is an animal i'll give him
that oh yeah i work in a bag those teeps
i was watching
mikey chandler you look good you look
good thank you it's it's improving
i have a feeling i want to try to like
not go too hard but you're going to try
to like knock it no no no no never i
won't even aim for your head i'll just
aim for your body like that's how you
should do it we're not trying for the
back of his neck
if he wants to all right i'm gonna wait
for give away my tactic
can we switch opponents now uh no we're
only doing one a show are you scared
just whatever you want to show this
one's gonna be uh and we have to get
like good footage of it too so it can be
its own like tick tock so if you could
try to get both we'll do right now tall
a tall version of it yes it's gonna be
special
i'm going for the performance of the
night bonus
more magic mine uh so one thing we uh
wanted to do um each week now is uh
looking to kind of see what the our
listeners are saying the show is in flux
we joked about the same crew and we just
want to see the feedback we're getting
and see how we're doing um so
everybody's encouraged to like and
comment on the youtube videos and and
just really let us know your thoughts um
i know george pulled some comments so
we'll we'll take a look at those and
just see what people are saying
okay listeners and viewers listeners
viewers yeah uh i like to say listeners
and viewers rather than fans i don't
like saying fans friends romans
gentlemen friends is good friends yeah
friends of the show
show hoes
the production quality on this
powerpoint is uh
yep
oh this one uh you guys are dope keep
these episodes coming all right there's
two likes on that one too yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i love it really encouraging all right
what else we got george is perfect for
the show knows when to talk and want to
let the main guys do their thing he
laughs a lot and always seems positive
he's a fast googler
that's from g doe thank you g oh that's
53 likes
oh damn that's beautiful that's
beautiful that is beautiful it's nice
this is my favorite
can you read that nick i can't wait nick
looks awful he could claim senior
citizen discounts and no one would doubt
the people want white mike as a regular
agree do you know what to do nick no you
know what to do nick also if there's if
he's available browse needs to be on
every episode he can make keep it up
after dark crew nice thumbs up and
that's eight likes they like our
co-hosts they like our replacements
that's nice yeah awesome
buffalo rick love the spin-off keep
growing the fake boy universe nice yeah
two livestreams right guys yeah three
seasons i'm liking this
disclosure.group
meatball is back yes one like one like
exclamation points i'm going to be
honest
i was the one like no one else liked it
you also made the comment but it's fine
it's nice to see people we're getting
positive feedback i love this this is
awesome let's keep them rolling yeah
that nick dude creeps me the [ __ ] out so
bad
we won't read his handle because that's
just rude that's just mean
it's it's okay underneath someone
replied dude looks like absolute [ __ ]
nah
that's why you're drinking magic okay
oh
and another reply he kind of looks like
the unit bomber which
i mean i see it's not a bad thing you
know he's a very accomplished idiot yeah
yeah when he sets his mind to something
he he blows [ __ ] up yeah that's terrible
okay okay uh all right
oh all right we're done with this okay
we're done with this take him down
no
[Laughter]
everyone missed the last one but we
won't say it on there yeah
oh man 25 minutes no time crawls when
you get insulted hey hey hey chin what
did you do this weekend i'm glad you
asked buddy
um well i want to ask you guys what you
guys did this weekend too no i asked you
so i went to my friends these are my old
roommates by the way and i'll tell you
why they're my roommates so i went to
their
knife launch party the guy's name is
bobby his wife
is but so he was a nobu sushi chef for
eight years and then they decided as a
couple to start their own company oh
that's i'm wearing their
shirt right now it's kitty knives
um cool sugar oh yeah yeah that is a
cool shirt actually here toss it to me
they're premium japanese knives so oh
was this a party tren what's up yeah
that's a party that was launch party oh
well better than a bunch of shots and
knives i know first it could happen
not that diverse no no you got it
there's like other stuff in there
there's a ton of girls too but they
don't see old dudes they don't want to
take shots
that makes sense and dude those asian
guys her cousins they're taller than me
like six four or six years i'm gonna
start a basketball team no
but um
[Music]
um yeah so
the reason i brought them up is because
oh that's bobbing stuff right there
it was their party yeah who looked at
all damn oj would have been in heaven
there
how do they make the not they make the
knives i'm sorry i i was texting uh
theo's uh producer in nashville so i
missed the beginning this was a he's
launching his own line of knives them
together gotcha so i don't know somehow
he's connected to making the night or
something with the knives so he it's
their business
but it's premium japanese knives they're
expensive they're like
200 300 800 crazy yeah yeah per knife
per knife
but they're amazing knives though
that's how my peanut butter sandwich is
going to be just those high-class knives
that are like super well folded and fine
yeah it's like carbon steel and whatever
else but so
when i first got the fire in the kid i
was living in orange county
right
so brennan's like you live in l.a right
i'm like yeah dude he goes you can be
there anytime at any time so i'm like
[ __ ] so as soon as the first day i got
the job i asked my friends who lived
next to the studios luckily they had a
room left over bless you
so i just stayed at that house five days
a week sorry it was okay even though i
lived in orange county i just stayed
there just in case and i would show up
to work like two hours three hours early
every day and then i remember thinking
like
this is kind of overkill they're never
going to call me during like a last
minute thing
oh you're wearing oh [ __ ] wearing the
merch yeah bro i like it looks nice it
looks nice and tight fitting it looks
like it fits your body very well what's
the back i use pins though
you don't have to tell us that you could
have just made it look like you're
getting involved can you pin your
sleeves to make your arms look bigger
don't
don't don't don't don't you think you
can give me a tooth going to the [ __ ]
gym
chin you're actually big don't say you
penny you're actually just so muscular
yeah 2x
a 2x i'll hook you up yeah yeah i'd wear
an xl
well then everyone's going to get shirts
in i'll just get your sizes later okay
well
i'm going to take a knife you said they
were like yeah
can we get one just like
and kyle can keep it but like we'll
advertise that we'll like cut a shoe in
half next week and then kyle gets the
knife and we get to cut a shoe in here
i'll talk to them this is a win-win
should we shout out their website yeah
oh i don't know but they have an
instagram q a knives oh that's that's
sweet yeah
but i think they're launched they're
actually going to launch launch in
august so i don't know if you buy right
now you can put your email in to get
notified for the launch there you go
um wait so let me finish i'm going to be
at another pre-order list for knives
how many are you on
i'm in the newsroom they're my friends
okay
so anyways i thought
maybe i could still be in orange county
and just show up to work but of course
the ones how i'm thinking about that
i get a call from brennan last minute i
thought it was a friday or saturday
well chris cyborg is at the studio he
forgot about it
so he's like can you just go there and
tell her i'm going to be there i'm like
[ __ ] drove to the studio pretending like
everything was fine oh yeah we expect
you to do blah blah talk to her her
boyfriend or whatever at the time
wait at the studio put everything and
just small talk the whole time while
brendan's driving over from i don't know
where he lived at that time but finally
we actually made the episode happen she
was actually cool the boyfriend husband
whatever it was cool too so it worked
out so me getting an apartment there
was necessary i smart
them i will say the most surprising part
to me
is boyfriend
chris cyborg
we don't have to elaborate we don't have
to lie
just
it bumped me
she is actually so sweet too i know i
have a person like she's so sweet i
would never expect that she uh
i don't know she she was actually it was
really sad because like one time rogan
and dana i know they're they're they're
like ripping on her and naturally
and uh she was just like they said who
why in a dress they said that she looks
like vanilli silva in a dress and then
dana i was like walking like
and something about cutting off her [ __ ]
to make waves sometimes
jesus christ
tony hinchcliffe said that part oh yeah
yeah that doesn't surprise you sorry joe
we did that i could fight featherweight
we were like oh who would say that oh
tony solid
banger
dope dope podcast though they recorded
it on a private jet yeah after after on
their phones or something right who did
uh it was dana white joe rogan and tony
hitchcock
yeah
did you did you guys see uh dana gave
that guy kyle from the milk boys like
250 000 in cash for his birthday yeah
just like a bag of cash but why just
just
like their friends and they gamble
together and
i think really it's essentially like a
sponsorship deal where like because the
naok boys rep ufc so hard they have they
have all the all the people on and it's
just like i don't know it's just like a
bonus yeah
deepening the relationship and and like
the now i bet it was the knock boys idea
they know like oh give me 250 000 cash
this will go viral yeah i know what
they're doing but shouldn't that money
go to like the fighters
that'd be nice i i i saw that argument a
lot they're like this is how much he
cares like
uh
he gave the nalkboy more than uh the
bantamweight champ got for his fight and
[ __ ] it's like it's coming out of his
pocket i mean
i don't know yeah it's his money he he's
the boss but
i don't know just like does kyle need
250 000 dollars
but just give it to mike i think he said
they were going to the strip club again
michael johnson deserves it give him
some money he put on a banger fight
jamie malarkey and michael johnson
that was a crazy fight i had michael
johnson
you you gambling no no no not gamble oh
just
like nick
him and michael you want to use keto
chips on the line yeah
my like bet almonds with each other
what'd you say nothing nothing uh but uh
yeah that that fight was awesome that
fight was [ __ ] amazing
and speaking of fights this weekend
ortega and yahya yeah yeah it's gonna be
a fire fight bang you've been doing this
no nick
i mean come on
all right i'm gonna send my i'm gonna
send my parlay
that uh uh yeah let's see
nick's picks making a return yeah nick's
picks are making a return i i i do like
it um i was about break even when we did
it on uh brendan's show you have a
spreadsheet sometimes i hope you know
you should do it on the shop show uh you
get one pick a week it was like for the
draftkings read or something yeah this
one we were still below the belt oh yeah
below the belt um and i just gave out
one pick but uh i still get multiple
tastes fighting yeah
i still get oops i still get
i have not been using this enough today
get these at chrissalia.com i'm assuming
hey
what was i saying uh
i still get multiple dms
per month asking me for my fight picks
and i have no i just got here nick's
picks
ask nick for his picks if you want them
really bad and i'm sure you do it's just
i'm just going i'm not picking for money
i you can just pick the ones that you
like
yeah shut up but as far as money choose
what are your pictures again
i'm gonna pick them up after i send this
to christian
all right so here's my parlay that's a
huge problem six legs
it's it's the lambo parlay that's what
we call them when we're just getting
real degenerate uh but i did track this
on my uh mma.tips
uh which is like a third-party tracker
so you can because it's in the mma
twitter handicapping world it's like bad
form just to like post your winning
tickets you know because then it's like
oh why aren't you showing what you lost
so this better mma that tips it allows
people to like you have to put in all
your bets before the fight so you
actually know if you're doing well or
not so i track this one which i don't
usually do when i do these degenerate
parlays but i feel so good about it we
got yair plus 130. you could get a way
better price for him like plus 150 right
now uh i don't i think ortega is not
gonna be able to take him down
um
if you if you if you do the mma math
though
korean zombie pissed up yair for five
rounds
ortega pieced up korean zombie some
people say korean zombie was concussed
the first round and that's why it was
that bad i don't know we'll see i think
i
i love that price don't sleep on brian
off his back though brian's off his back
t city they call him t city first i
don't see yeah you're
going for yeah i don't see it going on
the ground i i i just don't see it
what does four game mean i'm terrible
with gambling so what does it mean one
plus 130 for a game uh that's just what
they got like it's for the match to win
the cause it's basically like a template
how you would have for sports but it
doesn't
work out the same for fighters or
whatever um amanda limosch verse
michelle waterson she's minus 365
massive favorite i feel like michelle's
on her way out she's a mom she's making
money a lot of other ways i do love the
karate hottie though who doesn't look
can we get some pictures of the karate
body who doesn't love the karate hottie
um you got muslim
winning muslim solikov minus 175. that
one is tough uh versus uh uh
leon
lee jingling yeah that's it that's
microaggression but uh
i don't know i think that one stays on
the feet
they're both kind of low volume strikers
so it could be one of those where you
get a messy decision yeah jack shore
winning jack short that's that time
that's an auto play love you jack i i
actually think he i don't know i kind of
feel like there might be late money
coming on ricky simone so you might want
to wait till fight day to bet on jack i
think you'll get a better price but for
my parlay purposes didn't want to wait
and then uh who is my other
underdog
charles jordan charles jordan versus
i like i like charles for this fight so
do i i love shane burgos too though
there it's gonna be a great striking
battle oh hell it's gonna be dope he's a
awesome striking but i think shane
burgos takes damage and then he just
kind of falls apart a little bit but
dude he's been through wars yeah yeah
and his
knockout versus edson barbosa was super
scary he got like jabbed and then there
was like this delay and then he without
him getting hit and he just kind of like
fell over it was really scary it was
yeah and then uh punell soriano that
price has come down too you can get him
at like minus 230 right now
i think uh he will just
he's facing a dolce
i don't know his last name but i think
dolce will gas and we'll get punell like
round three dolls of us but dude that
parlays
i love everything about it except for
the top one yeah yeah yeah but if i do
get to that point yeah then i would
hedge uh and i would just put a bunch of
money on brian too um so what happened
to your party then so okay so
i bet four hundred dollars to win we'll
just call it ten grand it's like nine
thousand eight hundred yeah uh if i get
to that last fight it's either yaya wins
and i win ten thousand or brian would
win and i'd lose 400 instead i could bet
i could bet any amount of money but
let's say i bet four thousand dollars on
brian ortega then i either
if brian wins i win that 4 000 but i
lose the 400 i initially bet so i net 3
600 or if yair wins i win that 10 grand
but i lose the four grand that i been
bet against uh
ortega so then i would so that's either
i can have 10 grand or minus 400 as my
two options or six grand and three grand
as my two options if you get to that
last four point can you bet while the
fight's happening or you have to bet
yeah you can you can live that too but
the odds are subject to change yeah yeah
they they fly with it with the ebbs and
flows live betting's a whole different
[ __ ] ball game man
getting in like you're like yo he's got
him down
i'll i'll put 2 000 on a minus 500
favorite and then you're like god damn
it i'm hopping into
an ad meeting so uh anything you want to
plug um
his ass
no just uh when we have this 12 packs
with jeff dye no
two times ago i said it was coming out
soon i think it's gonna be coming out
soon it'll be on extra thick 12 packs
with jeff dye cool card show and yeah
all right maybe maybe the ad meeting
will get canceled and i'll be back i
don't know
we can only hope not good luck brother
peace out george
now the karate hottie girl can we get
her on the wheel i would do a minute
with her boxing i only need 30 seconds
yeah i was gonna say i wouldn't be a
minute but um if we could get her on the
wheel i will do it again i'll spin she's
adorable oh yeah which is a weird
horrible it's a weird way to describe a
fighter but she is like if you see her
in an interview
i mean the bangs
that blue top just beautiful
yeah i just want to say i get what nick
means but adorable wouldn't be the first
thing that came here you're only pulling
up pictures where she's all [ __ ]
ripped and [ __ ] and she
did we have there we go
that's what i'm talking about her
instagram would probably have some cute
that's also true
so kyle you're saying like
hypothetically if you can meet anyone in
the world
it might be karate hottie uh anyone in
the world
or just for that profession um no it
probably would not be karate how to
visit anyone if you can meet anyone in
the world who do you think i think i
know this answer but go ahead kyle i
like this question though george i would
like to hear what chin thinks uh if i
can meet anyone in the world and like
i'm going on a date with them
well not gonna be romantic i mean um
playing cards right what's your chance
probably probably uh haley williams
yeah i love her she's beautiful she's
the best i think she's single right now
so if you see this
damn me
she's a huge but uh yeah
what about what about you guys when we
when i saw you like pose this question
off air were you thinking romantically
um no i just kind of meant like in
general like
just like
like who do you want to be buds with
yeah that's right
my answer would have been nor mcdonald
yeah
he was like my number one this past
weekend
weekend bucket list guest
uh tried to have around met him briefly
at the adam carolla show just a passing
i made him laugh once i said the
producer of the adam carolla show looks
like adam you get
his sidekick
but now i don't know uh
michael jordan probably be pretty cool
okay interesting two degenerate gamblers
even after what he did to those kids in
that parking lot yeah yeah i didn't even
think about that you guys
can get yellow together as you guys look
at the bedding lines
do you got one [ __ ]
yeah
uh tim mcgraw okay interesting what he
and nelly did together
yeah hard to beat
hard to beat what about you just ruin
hip-hop music yeah
if you can meet anyone in the world
um honestly i'd probably go with
alexander ovechkin who's that the hockey
guy yeah he's a captain of the
washington capitals
i thought you were going to say
entourage
i would but look i mean there's just
something so interesting about him that
i just want like i've been a fan of this
guy for since i was 10
i would just love to meet him in person
he played
he recently played uh in a soccer game
for his father's old night like his
father played olympic soccer
yeah and he played they signed him to a
one-day contract in the offseason and
there's a video of him running down this
field and someone tries to go to sly
tackle him and he [ __ ] bodies him and
like throws a guy off of him and then he
scored in his first ever professional
soccer game
oh soccer yeah this guy is an absolute
his wife
wow
also gorgeous
she would be my second pick
yeah she's
she's fine eastern europe i'm assuming
she's russian
i need to find her instagram bro she's
gorgeous
and yeah anything you can find in a
catalog
freaking
if i could meet one person and this is
you know kind of possible because of my
new profession i'm in it would probably
be joey diaz right now i love uncle joey
i want to give him a hug shake his hand
uh me and my dad would watch uncle joey
a lot and laugh at the same kind of
humor because my dad's that generation
of growing up in the world
i love uncle he would love you he would
love you hell yeah have you um
talked to lee syed at all no i know he
went through a big weight loss journey
too yeah go to lee science instagram uh
you should hit him up i mean his p he
would uh go on patreon and talk to all
of his fans from like uh
the church of what's happening and uh
they would like that's how he would get
through going on his walks is he would
live stream and talk to the fans and
after a while he just got comfortable
enough to go on the walks and now he
lost like
200 pounds the 300 pounds the first
picture was the weight loss was it oh
[ __ ] sorry
yeah look at that look at that first
picture that is wild he's 10 pounds
lighter than me now
that and that's crazy that he was a
hundred pounds lighter than you started
at yeah
which is a wild thought i was 451 he's
shorter than me so we wore it about the
same but
it's hard it's hard work
to lose five pounds you should do that
you should do that go to george glow
like
live stream walks and [ __ ] hell yeah
that could be a fun idea if you guys
want it go in my comments on my youtube
let me know i'll freaking do it
but yeah i don't know if just reach out
i don't know [ __ ]
it's it's like one of those things
there's not really a reason but uh you
guys have a lot in common
you're following yourself and then that
would get you one step closer to joey
probably yeah
it's like uh the degrees of kevin bacon
have you guys ever heard of that yeah
yeah
like there's a whole website for it that
any actor you think of you just type in
and it's like you're this many people
away from being in a kevin bacon movie
dude
i don't know do it google we can all
i've i've played this game before and
i don't know it's not that hard to get
to most people but just knowing theo who
then knows david spade ugh david spade
knows [ __ ] everyone we could get to
anybody in three it's crazy damn how
would i google that
what the degrees of bacon degrees can
you go get the gloves
yeah
we're we're almost to that to that time
i got two i got a pair of boxing gloves
and then muay thai gloves uh do you have
but they're both like 16 ounce right no
one is eight and then
the others are 12. george you have
gloves don't i have 16 ounces and the
muay thais are 16 right 12. 12. maybe 16
and 12.
yep you guys can we next next time we
can have even but you guys can decide
amongst yourselves give me bullet 16. we
boxing today
one minute yeah cats fight club end of
the episode that's what the wheel is for
running you were here
yeah i didn't know it was going to be
today
you were already excited huh should i go
get michael yeah yeah uh 16 and 12.
hey good we can still pod we can yeah
the bigger gloves because
it
i think if you think you're going to win
then you should wear the smaller gloves
or you should wear the bigger that's
what i'm thinking yeah yeah yeah uh i
don't wanna hit this
but i feel like he's gonna really come
at you i know he's gonna come out he's
acting kind of modest and mild but i
think but if i hit him hard with my big
gloves so funny because there's like
this
how hard do i go and then waiting for
the other person to see how somebody
gets there
body shots uh you're not hard for me for
to get down to him oh yeah dude i gotta
i gotta lean down like well well i mean
okay we'll have to get headgear i i
guess that's fine for i'm not wearing
any anything no headgear for me
but i i just don't like why only body
shots
that's not even the sport it's a mouth
guard
that's not the sweet side
shots as well but i just don't want to
wear a headgear yeah yeah yeah well
that's that's ballsy we're gonna have to
feel like christian wouldn't either
we're gonna have to see what christian
is averse to like i don't know you're
not booking i i know he's auditioning
but let's come on
come on
like
you can take a couple more headshots but
you're gonna be fine it'll only add to
the rugged look that i think you should
be attempting to go for rather than the
leading man he can be a dead body on
power
we'll figure it out i'll [ __ ] do that
i would too dead ass whitey 100
i'm very excited for this i'll get my
camera as soon as everyone's ready
i don't wanna
i don't wanna get my camera is that is
that uh brandon yeah does he want does
he wanna come in and watch the i don't
think so
oh yeah i hope that was on camera
oh my gosh
where's the big gloves in
in my bag
in me sack
well this is awesome this is i've kind
of always wanted to be a matchmaker
promoter oh
ladies and gentlemen
we're
live
yeah where are we fighting huh uh right
here no back back there
back there because the uh the gopro will
be able to get it all he'll be able to
film it good we'll announce it
um
colored commentating uh george do you
want to come sit here we'll be the uh
will be the two-man booth i like it i'm
gonna stand over here with the minecraft
somebody should time have a timer on
their phone
hold on
get this um we're in 4k do you want this
in twenty
four timer uh uh [ __ ] what happened to
your computer it keeps on like the
screen keeps on oh word yeah we'll
change that so it's uh but i i can do it
on here okay
i try to figure out how to call me the
hiroshima honor
no worries
i hope no one heard that
uh i heard i'm from korea bro
and uh one sec here guys and then we're
gonna announce you
[ __ ]
all right going forward this is gonna
evolve we'll have walkout music
uh but right now um
uh
we should i guess we only have one
announcer all right i'll i'll i'll do it
all right
fighting
out of rhode island
the challenger
coming in at five two to five four ish
small five and a half watch out chewie
with a much much more accomplished older
brother
with a challenger
christian
meatball
and now
the returning champion
one of the biggest asians you'll ever
see 205 63
i'm guessing
coming fighting out of south korea
chin
yee
all right guys this is a one minute
exhibition match uh
chin said or christian said no only body
shots but i i think just whatever you
guys feel
uh and we have one knitting touch gloves
that you like too gentlemen
oh how dare you bro
and one sec sorry i wasn't ready again
and go
so we have christian trying to close the
distance with chin using his reach to
his advantage
no no stories there's no crying in
baseball so we got christian throwing a
couple nice hooks
chin are throwing those body uppercuts
like nick diaz
and they've got 40 seconds left i don't
think they realize that this is only a
minute
this looks like israel arasana's last
couple defenses i will not lie and i
know we should be critical here in the
booth we're not the warriors but this is
anti-climactic
uh
i really wish chin would just give him a
stiff jab to the nose real quick and uh
how long has it been uh hey whoa we
kicked it's only been 42 43
15 seconds what a disappointment it
doesn't take a lot for apollo to payload
a cheat you know 10 seconds
oh
he said he's gonna take the wind out
three seconds eat him eat those knuckle
sandwiches time ah
where's dean thomas dean
back at you one minute i'm tired george
george i just want to say if we ever
happen to end up on that wheel and we go
we got to go at it yeah that was we
don't break camera equipment i'm fine
yeah
uh i thought a minute came a long time
ago
no that was a minute chin had an extra
four ounces on his gloves and you can
tell by the windedness of his breath did
uh anybody were there any shots that
like me did you feel was christians
fired up he's like staring me down right
now
i didn't see any real good shots landed
yeah that was that was come on guys what
are we doing why did you why do we say
no head shots cause i don't know i feel
bad oh he feels bad chin like you're a
weaker again next week with headshots if
you guys are hey
i don't know i heard chin once i don't
want to hurt him again that's cat's
fights club but we'll find out next week
on the wheel this is gonna improve
honestly that was kind of disappointing
and i mean we're trying to get numbies
we're gonna get made fun of in the
reddit again more god damn it uh no i'm
just kidding guys this was really fun
this is a really fun episode i want ari
mantis uh oh i like i want arimanus you
cannot be a guest on the show unless
you're willing to be a part possible
participant in cats fight club and rule
number one about cats fight club tell
everybody you know about cats fight club
yes um oh plugs let's get out of here
chris first off my next opponent i want
kevin hart so we're gonna have to he's
gonna have to come on cats after
darkfield neither one of you guys are
passing usada so it's okay
that's like your that's like your
doppelganger except he's black you guys
are like the exact same like
exactly i i
sized him up i saw him hitting mitts i
was like all right let's see what he's
got i i'll i'll take him on he would
[ __ ] you up so bad he set it up
set it up matchmaker he gets his card
cleaned where i get mine my wash i can
hug him i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
come out of the bushes and one day he's
getting his car clean i'm just gonna
come out of the bushes with the gloves
on tell them what's up oh you're car
cleaned you want your glock lead yeah
exactly
exactly
that's why we need nick to be the play
by nick's gonna come out in the full
suit in the microphone
for it i honestly felt like i choked on
mike i wasn't happy with my performance
either but but uh
cats cats fight club is evolving yeah
it's the first it's the first match
we'll see we'll get better kfc
we're gonna get sued uh kyle what do you
got um don't really have anything going
on uh i told you guys i'm off tinder but
i'm back on it um because i'm a weak man
if you're a woman who wants to date kyle
set it in and we'd love to meet you on
air that'd be great
and uh yeah just my instagram kyle
varney underscore uh you know slide in
there baby
uh same thing chintzy everywhere
instagram youtube check out my friends
knives company
k-ray knives
another below deck podcast huge week two
new season started below deck med and uh
below deck down under and another
bachelor podcast bachelorettes also
started did that guy really put the
cinnamon in the salad uh he
there was no cinnamon in the salad after
the cinnamon and the beef oh okay yeah
the fruit yeah check out another podcast
network to see what we're talking about
yeah damn right uh you can find me at go
george go on youtube or on instagram at
georgeharris48
gang didn't queso
[Music]
[Music]
you